how's it going everyone it's Warren and
great news today because we have an
official Avengers in-game trailer to
update from Marvel Studios themselves it
has been stated that the marketing for
Avengers in-game would be very different
than any other Marvel film that we've
seen including Avengers infinity war and
so far that's remained to be true we've
only gotten one official teaser trailer
for Avengers in game and we've only
gotten one TV spot with the Super Bowl
it's clear that Marvel is being very
secretive with Avengers in game so no
spoilers for it at all get out and many
people have been beginning to wonder if
we will even get a second full official
trailer for Avengers in game well
thankfully we have heard from Marvel
themselves about the second trailer and
we've even heard about when tickets are
going to go on sale for Avengers in game
and speaking of which I'm still doing my
giveaway I'm giving away five imax
tickets so you and some friends can go
see Avengers end game in IMAX if you
would like to enter for a chance to win
all you have to do subscribe to my
channel hit that notification bell like
the video and comment down below with
your thoughts and your favorite
superhero or villain so as I mentioned
we have actually heard from Marvel
themselves the president of Marvel
Studios Kevin Feige gave confirmation
that we would in fact be getting a
second trailer in an exclusive interview
with comic book calm at a press event
for Captain Marvel they asked Kevin
Feige when another trailer for Avengers
and game would drop in which he did in
fact give confirmation that we would be
receiving another trailer even though he
did not give us an exact date he simply
said before the movie is released but
it's still great news that we got
confirmation that we will in fact be
getting a second trailer for Avengers
endgame and with that news we also got
the news that tickets for Avengers in
game will go on sale on April 2nd three
weeks before the movie comes out which
also means that we could probably expect
the second trailer to drop somewhere
around that time so be sure to be on the
lookout around that time for the second
Avengers in game trailer and so you can
get your tickets so that's it for the
latest news let me know what you think
about it in the comments down below and
let me know how excited you are to
finally get the second trailer and also
let me know what you're most excited to
see in Avengers
and game don't forget to subscribe
comment and like the video so you can
enter the giveaway and stay up to date
on everything relating to avengers
endgame and marvel as always thank you
all so much for watching
woof woof
[Music]